est-ce que vous avez vu que samsung
encore tombé que ce tabouret là
malheureusement ce truc là je voulais
changer les confinements faisant voilà
je suis bloqué avec en fait pour tout
vous dire j'ai une espèce de table
bourru qui se plie voyez comme ça doit
aussi le trouver la bonne position pour
mettre dessus et ne pas tomber
je sens qu'il va tomber et qui va se
casser avant la fin du confinement donc
c'est un moment ou un autre dans une
vidéo vous ne voyez en train de chuter
vous inquiétez pas c'est taboret je ne
suis pas très haut donc ça va aller
samsung a présenté au japon et en inde
pas moins de trois nouveaux smartphones
c'est intéressant parce que souvent les
smartphones sont présentés en asie avant
d'arriver si en europe
je vais donc tout vous détailler tout
vous expliquer vous présentez quelles
sont ses smartphones et essayer de
comprendre pourquoi est ce que samsung
présente aujourd'hui deux nouveaux
smartphones là bas et pas ici et qu'elle
est un petit peu l'adn de ces produits
on va essayer de sentir un petit peu le
marché avant toute chose on est toujours
dans une période de confinement liés aux
coronavirus glv une fois de plus pas
vous reparler du courant des russes mais
je vous ai demandé il ya quelques jours
de m'envoyer des petites vidéos de vous
chez vous en train de vous filmer tout
ça pour nous expliquer comment est ce
que vous vivez vous pendant cette
période de confinement histoire de
partager qu'on soit tous ensemble
consommant de l'amour et compagnie
je vous invite à m'envoyer vous votre
vidéo vous l'envoyer à l'adresse qui
s'affiche en dessous amour @ monsieur le
point fr vous filmez votre smartphone
quelques petites secondes mais voilà
comment ça se passe à la maison regarder
je vous montre un peu je travaille là
tiens j'ai des enfants pas des enfants
voilà comment juil voilà comment
j'arrive à me distraire quelles sont mes
activités
l'histoire qu'on partage un petit peu et
puis c'est beaucoup plus sympa c'est
convivial et compagnie vous pouvez
m'envoyer ça et on se regarde tout de
suite la vidéo du jour selimi sucre eux
on est mardi 18
voilà j'aime bien ta vidéo pal instants
avant d'aller me coucher parce que je
bosse de nuit pour tuer le temps avec
les enfants
bah là depuis quelques jours on fait
activités scolaires
enfin pour la petite c'est maternelle
donc ces voix-là activités pour les
enfants de 5 ans près pour la petite
dernière c'est plus les jeux lego duclos
voilà et puis bon après le petit temps
de relaxation netflix amazon prime et
puis bon on va dire moi
je bosse la nuit donc je bosse dans un
foyer occupationnel donc va
réquisitionner donc
donc on va dire je je m'ennuie pas voilà
et pour ma femme bat normalement ça sera
à la maison dans dc pas longtemps ou
voilà on va écouter bon courage à 12
pour ceux qui sont confinées à la maison
et puis garder le moral et puis bah
comme on dit il faut rester positif et
comment doit pas de serrer la main
longue vie et prospérité salut merci
donc pour l'envoi de cette vidéo très
content chaque fois je me retrouve pas
mal et je suis super content de pouvoir
les visionner déjà les découvrir et puis
bien évidemment qu'on puisse tout seul
et partager ensemble
donc ça c'est hypra coûte trois
smartphones je vous disais qu'ils ont
été présentés par samsung pas au même
endroit passe sur le même marché
mais trois smartphones très intéressant
le premier smartphone milieu de gamme
c'est le samsung galaxy à 41 qui vient
remplacer le samsung galaxy à 45
smartphone je pense qu'il devrait
arriver qui a été présentée par un
opérateur qui s'appelle docomo qui est
un opérateur japonais
c'est donc un produit qu'on pourrait
imaginer en france venir remplacer lui à
40 existence à jouer la pole déjà
expliqué il ya deux autres produits il
ya aussi le samsung galaxy n 21 et m31
ce sont deux dénominations qu'on ne
connaît pas particulièrement sont deux
produits d'entrée de gamme qui s'adresse
au marché indien
je ne suis pas sûr que ces produits on
les voit arriver un jour ici en europe
vous dis en europe mais vous n'êtes
peut-être pas vous en europe d'ailleurs
dit moi une fois de plus où est ce que
vous êtes marqué le mois en bas en
commentaire est-ce qu'à des personnes ça
ça m'intéressait beaucoup
est-ce que vous qui regardez vous
habitez en inde est ce qu'il y a des
personnes qui habitent en inde et qui
regardent la chaîne si oui vous me
marquer en bas en commentaire je serais
curieux parce que justement sur des
produits qui se destinent au marché
indien bons coups il ya un vrai sens et
s'intéresse en malaisie de marquer le
moindre commentaire
justement je vous disais s'est produit
je pense pas qu'ils arrivent parce que
l'entrée de gamme aujourd'hui c'est
samsung en europe c'est la gamme à la
gamme m
elle n'existe pas ici vous serez très
surpris que ces produits arrivent et je
serai surpris d'ailleurs qu'ils aient
une dénomination tout cas comme m21 et
m30 tient toujours est il que ces
produits existent là bas alors mauvais
c'est un gros si tu es un petit peu tout
ça on veut d'abord centrée sur le
samsung galaxy à 41
tout est ici début d'année sais pas si
vous vous souvenez je vous avais montré
ce ne sont des présenté le galaxy à 51
et a71 vous emmener à las vegas os et
ios je voulais montrer rapidement
aujourd'hui de publier
le test sur ces deux smartphones il
montre aussi le galaxy note bis light
n'est toujours pas testé ce qui l'a
d'ailleurs si un jour il arrive
j'aimerais bien pouvoir à vous en parler
tester c'est pas sûr mais si ça se fait
ça serait cool et donc ça paraît normal
qu'ils viennent renouveler toute leur
gamme
on voit aujourd'hui à 51,71 on pourrait
imaginer l'année prochaine à 52,72 vous
avez compris un peu l'histoire de la
dénomination sa part assez logique donc
à 41 cas étaient présentés au japon et
qui affiche des spécifications
techniques assez intéressant aussi de
comprendre un peu à qui s'adresse ce
qu'est ce que ce produit raconte comme
histoire puisque mon avis va arriver
d'ici très peu de temps alors l'écran
notre journée a évidemment un écran
amoled 6,1 pouces et du full hd plus de
1400 par 1080 pixels excusez moi je
reçois des notifications en même temps
c'est formidable on est sur un ratio 29e
très allongée
je ne veux rien merci beaucoup je suis
là jouent dur et qu'on va ne vienne tout
simplement qui est là pour avoir il
souffre d'un petit peu plus allongé qui
va porter deux choses effectivement un
confort de lecture ce que vont parler
des films au format 21 9ème au format 18
9e et puis côté très intéressant d'un
format plus allongée c'est une très
bonne tenue en main vous le tenez bien
c'est quelque chose qui est assez long
et qui plutôt pas mal
un écran qui occupent 89% de la face
avant et qui est une petite encoche sur
le haut de sa part est absolument pas
des causes ans sur ces typologies de
produits côté performances on tourne sur
un média texte 1 et llopez 65
une fois de plus on est dans le milieu
de gamme ça semble donc fonctionner 4
gigas de ram 64 giga de stockage
extensible grâce à une carte microsd
jusqu'à 512 ziga on a donc une
caractéristique milieu de gamme en
termes de performance vous ferez donc
tourner pas mal de jeu pas de choses
trop gourmand mais qu'une fois de plus
un smartphone milieu de gamme donc il a
des caractéristiques milieu gamme ça
paraît logique
la photo ça c'est un point très
intéressant parce que c'est un des
usages majeur aujourd'hui on a un triple
capteur à l'arrière un grand-angle 48
mégapixels trouvera f 2.0 qui semblerait
bien fonctionné lorsque vous avez
beaucoup de lumière en extérieur je ne
suis pas sûr qu'en fin de luminosité ça
soit extraordinaire ça me paraît aussi
normal il faut de plus si vous êtes très
bonne photo faible luminosité il faut
noter sur la gamme s où tout est un peu
plus cher mais par contre vous aurez le
rendu de qualité
un deuxième cas façon ultra grand-angle
123° 123 degrés c'est la vision de
l'oeil humain qui ouvre à f 2.2 et puis
une caméra tough fameuse caméra time of
lights une caméra de 5 mégapixels couvre
f 2.4
les caméras dof elle va vous servir
lorsque vous allez faire une photo en
mode portrait elle va venir mesurer la
distance entre l'appareil entre la
personne devant pour faire vraiment un
flou d'arrière plan
on l'a un peu à quoi va vous servir
aujourd'hui la caméra tough sur ce
produit
vous avez une caméra de celle fille de
vingt-cinq mégapixels qui ouvre à f 2.2
opus se ressemblent aux récents le taf
une batterie de 3500 milliampères or
avec un chargeur rapide de 15 watts et
pas le chargement plus rapide une fois
depuis sa blessure le milieu de gamme on
aurait pu avoir un changeur de 25 points
que vous iriez plus vite
15 watts 3500 milles intérieur ça me
semble fonctionner tout ça se
rechargerait bien évidemment en usb type
c'est un capteur d'empreintes qui cette
fois ci se trouveraient sous l'écran sur
ce produit c'est plutôt bien une
certification qui pèse 68 résistants à
l'eau et à la poussière vole un petit
peu l'idée de ce produit pour ça tombe
bien évidemment sur one live 2.0 basé
sur l'android 10 ont nourri un
smartphone avec de la 4g et non pas avec
de la 5g
ça me paraît assez logique si vous
voulez que l'a5 j'y arrive dans sept
premières années 2020 d'abord sur les
smartphones les plus haut de gamme
ensuite on se retrouvera dans la
deuxième partie de l'année sur les
smartphone milieu de gamme
et puis tout ce qui va être un petit peu
entrée de gamme on retrouvera en 2021
donc c'est normal que sont humides haut
de gamme on ne trouve pas de 5 g pour
nommant qui se lie à rennes bien des
collants de la nano singing évidemment
smartphones qui existe en trois couleurs
en bleu en blanc et en noir et qui sera
disponible au japon à partir de juin
2020 donc j'imagine qu'on pourrait
potentiellement la voir s'ils arrivent
chez nous en septembre probablement
septembre 2020 avoir à l'ifa à berlin
si toutefois ce produit est présenté et
cilly fada rhin a bien lieu à cause des
questions du coroner house
mais là où ça devient encore plus
intéressant c'est quand on parle des
deux autres smartphones galaxy n21
galaxie elle 30 ha parce que l'on se
plonge jeunes qui peu dans l'inconnu on
n'a pas de références et comme son
galaxy à 40
on peut un peu venir comparer alors très
clairement le à 40 ans est une évolution
due à 40 correspond aux standards
actuels
il n'y a rien de bien d'un grain de bien
révolutionnaire mais une fiche technique
qui est revu corrigé et amélioré mais
kim en tout cas que samsung continue à
travailler sur son positionnement en
améliorant ses produits pour venir se
battre face à la concurrence chinoise
voilà un petit peu l'idée alors aux
nôtres regarder ce qui se passe tout
foutait du m21 et du hem 31 août et
marquer la solitude fiche ça c'est pour
l'inde je pense pas qu'on les ait chez
nous cela je pense pas qu'ils arrivent
en europe et reste du monde je suis pas
sûr sur le gr t on un écran de 6 points
4 pouces et de la molette c'est du full
hd + voyez garenne bien dingo là dessus
on va voir un processeur 1 exynos 9611 4
ou 6 giga de ram 64 ou 128 giga de
stockage c'est exactement le même socle
le même processeur pour le m 31
on aurait par contre là une seule
version 128 go de stockage
on aurait une grosse batterie de 6000
millions terreur et voiliers pour voir
qu'on est sur un smartphone qui je pense
ne va pas coûter très cher moins de 200
euros il est quand même relativement
sérieux au niveau des spécifications
techniques et six de leurs charges 15
mois qu'il faudra un petit peu s'armer
de patience pour mieux recharger son
smartphone avec une batterie de cibles
ennemies en période en termes de photos
on a tous peur principal de 48
mégapixels sur le m 21 ans que sur l
notre auteur vous avez un capteur de 64
mégapixels en ultra grand-angle d'un
côté comme de l'autre dans tous les cas
c'est un 8 mégapixels avec un champ de
vision de 123 degrés rien de bien d'un
go on assure le m21 une caméra of time
of light comme sur le à 41 pour venir
mesurer la distance pour les modes
portrait tandis que sur le n 31 on
aurait une caméra de maquereau de 5
mégapixels coudre f 2.4
bon moi ça personnellement j'y crois pas
normalement les revenus s'ils paraissent
pas complètement dingue la macro
pourquoi pas d'ailleurs dit moi vous
vous utilisez les maquereaux est-ce que
vous utilisez la macro charvaux
smartphone mois par an et non pas avoir
testé plusieurs fois et sur plusieurs
smartphones j'ai jamais bien été happé
par la macro sur les smartphones pour
l'instant tout cas ça me semble pas
complètement dingue et puis les usa je
suis pas sûr qu'il soit vraiment là dans
les deux cas on aime caméra de saïfi 20
mégapixels sur le n 21 et 32 me à pixel
sur le m 31 lecteur d'empreintes
digitales qui se situe à l'arrière de
chaque produit c'est pas déconner non
plus sur un smartphone pas très cher sur
un smartphone d'entrée de gamme
dans les deux cas on tourne sur moi
nuage de baser sur un android dix double
sim plus la notion of hawaii un petit
peu l'histoire un smartphone assez
basique mais qui par contre je trouve en
termes de spécifications techniques est
quand même relativement robuste alors
qu'est ce que ça nous devons tous enfin
le marché indien sai intéressante
puisqu'il ya ben
beaucoup d'acteurs tu sois chimiques ce
soir et demi il ya une guerre qui est
extrêmement féroce on peut le ressentir
nous ici en europe mais vous pouvez
ressentir partout dans le monde je
dirais mais sur des marchés comme le
marché indien encore plus ça se bat
énormément pour proposer les meilleures
solutions aux meilleurs tarifs qu'est ce
qu'il faut retenir un petit peu de cette
idée là eh bien c'est ce qu'on a vu
l'année dernière l'année dernière on
2019 samsung a vraiment opéré un virage
au niveau de sa stratégie et notamment
dans l'entrée milieu de gamme sur le
marché européen en unissant la gamme j
qui est elle entrée de gamme et la gamme
mac est un milieu bien pour faire une
seule et même gamme de la gamma qui
regroupe justement l'entrée de gamme et
milieu de gamme avec une nouvelle
numérotation qui part de 10 jusqu'à 80
90 81 is nothing on les a pas eues on va
donc très clairement en fonction de la
numérotation de vos smartphones dans
quelle gamme vous vous situez plus
chiffrée bah voilà le chiffre est au
plus c'est beau vous avez compris un peu
l'histoire est là ils font exactement la
même chose ils déroulent leur stratégie
même si la dénomination n'est pas la
même en inde c'est exactement la même
chose
ces fleurs face à la concurrence
chinoise s'armer face aux autres pour
gagner des parts de marché et une passe
et sa distance et et a toujours dans la
course parce qu'effectivement
aujourd'hui samsung est numéro 1 ils
sont forcément numéro 1 par le très haut
de gamme par des produits qui sont
vachement bien très intéressant
notamment le samsung galaxy est l'ultra
dont je vous ai parlé un jour un
smartphone 5 g qui est vraiment génial
mais il faut aussi être évidemment
présente là vous allez faire un plus
gros volume de vente c'est-à-dire sur
l'entrée de gamme et sur le milieu de
gamme
parce que même si le très haut de gamme
reflète ce que vous savez faire ça sert
à faire valoir aussi l'entrée et milieu
de gamme
voilà donc un peu la stratégie
aujourd'hui qu'adopte samsung et qu'elle
continue à dérouler qu'elle continuera
de jouer dans les temps à venir il faut
donc s'attendre à voir à ce que toute la
gamme se renouvellent je pense que le
milieu de gamme va davantage se
renouveler à partir de midi
2020 jusqu'à fin 2020 pour vous proposer
des smartphones 5g et encore plus en
2021 qu'est ce que vous en pensez tout
ça est ce que vous êtes d'accord avec
moi est ce que vous pensez effectivement
que ça me souviens raison de venir
multiplier l'offre de la rendre plus
lisible moins complexes pour venir
régler des consommateurs par rapport à
la concurrence chinoise qui est
extrêmement dur sera marché très
compliqué et est ce que vous pensez que
la 5g peut être un levier sur l'entrée
et le milieu de gamme tout en sachant qu
effectivement les abonnements vont être
forcément plus cher c'est pas
aujourd'hui où en est l'inde par rapport
au déplacement de la salle j'ai
d'ailleurs si vous savez vous de me le
marquer en bas en commentaires en tout
cas sur le marché européen la 5g arripe
la 5g commence vraiment arriver un peu
tous les côtés ça va s'unir faut remiser
ça commence on est dans le début de la
5g ça commence effectivement en 2020 ça
va progresser en 2021 et elle est
carrément plus loin en 2022 pour arriver
sur zone 5 g de tous les objets
connectés mais ça sera dans les années à
venir dans un second temps donc on en
reparlera ultérieurement sur ce je vous
invite bien évidemment à m'envoyer vos
vidéos pendant le confinement me dire
comment vous allez comment ça se passe
chez vous me donner un petit peu aussi
d'ailleurs vous avez des astuces à
partager pour occuper le temps libre et
faire que ce soit un plus convivial et
beaucoup mieux vous pouvez y aller
envoyez moi votre vidéo vous avez
l'adresse amour @ monsieur leur point fr
je partagerai au début d'une de mes
vidéos sur ce je vous embrasse aux
rendez-vous dès demain on voit qu'il ya
parlé de texte pour les soins dont des
bisous ciao
[Musique]
où
vous
[Musique]